foreign
[Music]
okay there we go okay hello everyone I'm
xiaohu a research fellow in Simon's this
fourth semester and later I will join
Waterloo as a assistant professor
um I'm generally interested in designing
algorithms for database queries from
different aspects for example the
scalability low latency learnability
obliviousness and in today's talk I will
just cover some of my research on
Nursery parallel joint algorithms and I
hope you can find some interesting idea
from this talk
so the first question is what is joy
Joy is a binary operator in relational
algebra given two relations with some
common attributes it defines all pairs
of tuples with the same value on the
common attribute
so this is example of employee joint
department on the attribute Department
name
and when all tuples have the same joint
value it's just degenerates to a calcium
product
we will have more relations involved we
can use the joint operator together with
some other operators such as selection
projection or even aggregation to ask
more complicated analytical queries
in these three queries you can see that
the core component is exactly the join
so what does joint query compute
it is essentially the patent matching
problem in the hype in the instance
hypergraph
the instance hypograph use vertex to
represent values in the domain of the
attributes and use hyper edges to
represent tuples
in the lines rejoin a b join BC join c d
every simple path from a to d is a joint
result and in a star join ABC join 81
join BD to join CD3 every star-like
subgraph is a result
and in the Triangle joint a b joint BC
joint AC every triangle is a result
so the general joint query will find all
those subgraphs with a specific pattern
this problem in general is NP hard if
we're taking both the query and the data
complexity in your account so in this
line of research we focus on the data
complexity and assume that the query has
constant size
and our goal is to find the most
efficient way to compute the join
results
in the last 20 years no need to process
and analyze big data has invigorated
this traditional area with a lot of
fresh challenges
for example large volume data cannot be
stored and processed by a single machine
people then developed a massive Power
Systems such as mapreduce and Spark for
data processing then how to design
algorithms that can skill to more than
100 or 1000 machines without keeping the
communication cost no
so we study algorithm for those systems
in the message parallel computational
model noted as MPC model
in MPC model there are P servers
connected in a complete communication
Network and the input data is
distributed across the servers
computation will proceed will proceed in
sequential runs
in each round all the servers exchange
message first and then perform some
local computation independently
after synchronization all the servers
will enter into the next round
algorithm in this model are first
measured by the number of rounds and
then the load which is defined as the
maximum size of message received by any
server in around
as the system synchronization is very
expensive we only consider algorithms
running in accounts number wrongs
so the question is given a join query a
database and P servers how to design
accounts around the algorithm for
computing the join results with minimum
load
next I will show some challenges in
designing an NPC joint algorithm
suppose we want to compute the basic
truth table join r1ab join r2bc okay
we can simply pick a random hash
function which Maps the join value to a
server ID then all the tuples will be
sent to the server whose ID matches the
hash value
okay it works well if all the joint
values have relatively small degree in
both relations
okay
however in the worst case all tapouts
have the same join value all data will
be set sent to the same server no matter
which hash function is applied to the
Joint attribute
okay so the in the worst case the load
complexity can be as large as the input
size
so how to deal with the data skill
we first Need A Primitive to handle this
bad case of calcium product the idea is
quite cute we just organize the P
servers into a root P times 0p grid okay
for every Tuple from the R1 we randomly
select the row and send all send this
Tuple to all the servers in this row
and symmetrically for every type of from
R2 we randomly choose a column and send
this table to all servers in this column
you can easily check that every pair of
tapos will meet on some server and with
high probability every server will
receive roughly an overview p tuples
with this stream team now we are able to
handle the data skill in the two table
join you can view it as MPC version of
the sort merge join okay after searching
okay all the joint the join values whose
type of phone inside one server can be
computed locally and we are left with
the join values whose double spend over
more than one server and they are at
most the P minus one such values and
their potential heavy heaters
okay then we need to allocate the
servers proportional to their input and
output size and then use the natural
Loop join to compute their calcium
products in parallel
and us this algorithm is already output
optimal with the load complexity in this
form
um okay I won't go into details but okay
this is a very small example to show how
to deal with data skill
when we move to General joins in NPC
model we will meet the challenges
brought by data skill and more important
more complicated drawing conditions
a common approach in the literature is
to investigate the structured property
of the pattern the query typograph for
example the acyclicity or hierarchy or
canonical Edge covering okay I want to
go into the details here but we have MPC
day on September 27th and I hope on that
day I will have time to cover more
interesting algorithms for MPC join in
the lecture
so next I want to share with you a big
picture of the joint algorithm in that
PC model and some interesting uh
difference with the sequential brand
model
the first result is about output optimal
algorithm for acyclic drawings
so in the literature more than 40 years
ago the Yellow Taxi algorithm can
already compute all the acyclic joint
output optimally
however we observe a separation between
our hierarchical and the non-arh
hierarchical joint in NPC model
and more importantly the output
optimality for none are hierarchy join
is quite limited to very small output
size okay
the second separation is on the worst
case to Optimal algorithm okay in the
ram model there is a very nice and
unified algorithm that can compute all
the join results and the complexities
depend depends on the fractional Edge
covering number of the joint query
and the enacting model the worst case
optimal algorithm are recently proposed
for a cyclic joint and several class of
signal joints and we also observe a
higher lower bound okay for some
specific cyclic drawing and this
complexity no complexity depends on the
fractional Edge packing number of the
joint query okay so you can see the
separation here
the third question third parties on the
output optimal algorithm for secular
joints and there is a nice Panda
algorithm that computes all the joint
results
um and whose time complexity depends on
the submodular width of the joint query
but there is no counterpart non-trivial
counterpart in MPC model
so there are a lot of interesting
questions left in these three blocks
uh the first big question is worst case
optimal MPC joint algorithm this is the
joint I just mentioned so it has a
rather simple structure with adjoin b e
joycf join ABC joint Def and it has
fractional Edge covering number as 2 and
the fraction of edge packing number is
three and also the upper bound and lower
bounds are already matched a big
question is what's the worst case
optimal algorithm for General joints and
we conjecture that the worst optimality
will be related to the max between
fractional Edge covering number and Edge
packing number but it's still open for
both upper bound and lower bounds
the second question is to understand the
output optimal algorithm for MPC join
so this lines rejoin is the only non-air
hierarchical drawing on which the output
optimality is well understood and this
optimality is in terms of piecewise
function so when the output size is
small the classical
parallel young taxi algorithm is optimal
and when output size is sufficiently
large the worst case Optimum will take
over and when the output starts for in
between this region and our output
optimal is algorithm is optimal uh so
the question is what's the output
optimal algorithm for more complicated
than our hierarchical joints
the third question is how to use matrix
multiplication to speed up joint
processing
so in the ram model there is a very nice
work for listening triangles use fast
matrix multiplication a natural question
is can we have some used similar
techniques to obtain output optimal
algorithm for triangle join we show some
lower bound but we don't know whether
this is optimal and so this question is
still open for both upper bounds and the
lower bounds a general question is how
to use this technique for General joints
we also want to compute the aggregate
aggregate function on top of the join
results for example the sparse matrix
multiplication can be represented as a
very basic joint aggregatory and we
already have some output optimal
algorithm for computing sparse Matrix
modification in NPC model but this is
still generally open how to compute
other joint queries efficiently
uh okay that's the question is uh maybe
a big direction is to study the topology
or MPC model so in the previous one we
talked about the homogeneous NPC such
that all the servers communicate with
the same uh bandwidth parameter and the
same latency and they are conducted by a
complete Network
um a high level idea in this model is
that we want to take the communication
topology into account
um
and we already have some initial results
for setting the sections searching and
natural drawing but I believe there's a
lot of work can be done in this
interesting model okay thank you
[Applause]
questions
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]